my name is Joseph lappen and what I
really care about is storytelling and
design thinking to drive growth and make
meaningful impact in people's lives when
I first sort of started realizing how
passionate I was about storytelling I
think started way back in the beginning
of my journey
in college at Stetson University and I
went on and got an MFA in creative
writing in Florida International
University what got out of that MFA was
something I never would have expected in
my professor Les Stanford he taught me
about Joseph Campbell in the hero's
journey and Joseph Campbell and the
hero's journeyed is the philosophy and
foundation and architecture of
Storytelling so I graduated from MFA and
I met my wife and moved out to my wife
in Los Angeles where I was a journalist
and really was putting this storytelling
practice to a practical use of society
as a journalist but what I found was
that still it wasn't really the end of
my journey I needed to keep going I
needed to keep going I was doing a lot
of research on design thinking and
ultimately landed on Stanford their
entrepreneurship Innovation program
and I just called up and they're like
listen you want design thinking this is
the program for you but let me tell you
it's only the beginning for you so I
think design thinking was to keep the
Joseph Campbell analogy going that was
the Call to Adventure everything that
I'm doing professionally and creatively
has been impacted by this program I
literally have transformed the way I
approach leadership creative thinking
team building collaboration based on not
only the research that I came across but
the philosophies and the thinking there
was always a part of me growing up in my
town Clinton Massachusetts where I'm
from I always knew I thought differently
through this entrepreneurship and
Innovation you know program
what I learned was that
motivating factor that part of me was
something that could be my superpower
and ultimately I believe that I can do
that through storytelling but now I'm
saying I can do that through product
development and really what I'm trying
to do is I'm building an integrative
marketing company I want to build a
journey for individuals to help them
become the people they're meant to be
there's themes running through these
programs of great companies I feel that
I have seen a vision for how a company
should work
I have seen by just listening to the
stories the people in this program how
amazing it could be to run a company
that was focused on design thinking and
creative potential that's what motivates
me is leaving an impact and building
something where other people can unleash
their credit potentially